Kumar I'm working in your bank uh I
understood many Hinduism now only
because most of the Hindus doesn't know
what vas
is but uh do you agree all vas
scriptures and we chapters everything is
it correct then some section of the
people in Hindu only uh learning that
vas not many Hindus are learning they're
not allowed to learn but those religion
leaders also not practicing the same
what vas says is it correct then why
they are doing like that please answer
me thank you a good question the first
question what do I believe with
everything what The Vedas say Point
number two The Vedas only a Selected Few
Hindus learned people they read others
are prevented from Reading why Point
number one do I believe in everything of
the Veda if you analyze Allah says in
the Quran in Surah chapter number 13
verse number 38 Allah says that we have
sent Revelation in every
age in every age we have sent a
revelation by name only four are
mentioned in the Quran Tor Zab in and
the
Quran the Quran is the last and final
revelation of Allah subhana wa taala
which was revealed to the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad sallallah Al
wasallam now there are the person who
asked me in Bombay also that can I
consider Veda to be the word of God do I
consider V totally to be correct see by
name only four are mentioned Tor Zab in
and Quran but there were many books
revealed by Allah subhana tala now
regarding V can I consider with the word
of God since V is not mentioned by name
in the Quran or any authentic Hadith I
cannot say for sure that it is the word
of God I can say maybe it is maybe it is
maybe maybe not but even if vaa was the
word of God it was meant for those
people and for that time today we have
to follow the last and final Revelation
that is the Glorious Quran for the of
humankind regarding a question do I
believe everything in the v Allah says
in the Quran in Bak CH number 2 verse
number
79 W to those who write the book with
their own hands and then say this from
Allah to traffic with it for a miserable
prize W to those for what they earn V to
those for what they write now we realize
that all the previous scriptures of all
Mighty God by the passage of time they
have got corrupted they have been
changed today we don't have the inine in
the pure form the Bible that we have it
is not the inil which was revealed toam
they have changed in passage of time so
even if Veda was the word of God today
it has not maintain this pure form and
all the Hindu Scholars they
agree so Allah says in Surah hij 15
verse number 9 that we have revealed the
Quran and we shall guide from corruption
Quran is also called as the fan the crit
to judge right from wrong so what I say
that whatever is matching with the Quran
in The Vedas I accept it to be
true what doesn't match I leave it aside
because Veda hasn't maintained his pure
form according to Hindu Scholars so what
I say whatever matches with Quran I say
I've got no objection this part may be
the word of God but I don't agree
everything of The Vedas there are many
unscientific points in the vaa I can
give a talk on that which I don't intend
giving I can give hundreds of scientific
things mention in the vas so what I say
that this is the fan the criteria you
check with this if it matches with this
we agree it to be that part as to be
true hope that answer the
question do we have a question from the
sister's side do we have a non-muslim
sister who has a
question good evening everybody I'm arti
I'm an engineering student um I believe
that most religions are just a set of
beliefs Hinduism is a belief Islam is a
is a belief Christianity is a belief uh
and most most major religions like the
Islam or the Hindu Hinduism or the
Christianity have been formed through
ages they have they have come past
through a lot of lot of Ages so they can
there can be a lot of additions and
subtractions uh which can add value to
the religion and which can also uh cause
some kind of demolishing to the to to
the name of the religion itself so my
question is why do we have to stick on
to few religious books like the Quran or
the vas to follow a life of our own why
can't we just take the rights the
positives and the negatives and leave
the negatives alone and take the
positives of the Quran and take the
posst of the vas alone and and lead a
life of good and and no matter what for
example no matter what the Vedas say or
no matter what the Quran says I believe
that a man should have a single wife and
I would definitely I would definitely
not agree upon the fact that the vas
contain something like that or the Quran
contains something like that it is up to
my conscience to leave off the negatives
of however great or religious book might
be and take the postures of the book
alone and why why are we here to even
discuss about the the I mean why are we
here to even discuss about the the
differences and similarities between the
two great religions why can't we just
take the postures of both religions and
just lead a life of our own very good
that's my question sisters asked a very
good
question a very good question a very
relevant question that why should we
follow religion why Hinduism why Islam
why Christianity why not follow the good
things of all and that's it finish who
will decide what is good what is
[Applause]
bad for example in America wearing
skirts and shorts is common Western
Country it is modest so for there
wearing skirts and short is modest if
you were in chenai if a girl walks on
the streets with shorts and skirts you
will call it immodest including your
sister even you say she is a modest so
what is modest in America is not modest
here when I went to America a few years
back there was a person who told me that
you Indian wom you're immodest I was
shocked why how come Indian women are IM
modest because when you wear the S you
show your belly so for the American for
the American the women showing the belly
is IM modest so who will decide if you
go to certain Muslim countries the Arab
countries looking at a woman staring at
a woman is IM modest here as long as you
don't touch a woman you can talk to her
you can look at her it's modest
therefore when you greet the Indian they
say namaste without touching in the
Western countries it is common that you
shake hands to shaking hand between a
lady and a man is
Modesty as long as you shake an and
don't touch any other part of the body
in some Western country is modest in
other Western countries kissing a woman
on the lips and the cheek is modest in
some Western countries you can do what
you want the male and the female as long
as you do willingly it is
modest who will decide who will decide
who will decide if you go to America
they nude beaches there is a ship I read
in the times of India two months back a
new Cruise a nude Cruise nude everyone
in the ship will be nude for them it is
modest who will decide the best person
to decide is the creator sister now I'm
asking you who will decide what is right
what is wrong who will decide and if you
say that select the best I'm with you I
agree with you sister select the best of
all the religions so that's what I've
done I have selected the best from the
vas but but what is best is not best for
you that's the problem I'll discuss that
also I challenge I challenge any human
being to point out a single principle of
Islam which is Against Humanity as a
whole
single I challenge I say I'm not speak
on behalf of the other Muslims I'm
putting my head on the guillotine I
challenge anyone anyone yes there may be
made non Muslim may think certain thing
is wrong for example the sister
disagrees with a man having more than
one wife I'll discuss that inshallah
after I give you the answer you'll be
convinced inshallah God willing you'll
be convinced for example if you ask a
problem 2 plus two is how much if you
don't know the answer I'll give you the
answer now once you know the answer you
get convinced so what you have to
discuss sister the things which you
don't agree you can come on the
microphone and tell me I am a just
student I'll try my L best with Allah's
help to try and reply now though the vas
say you can marry more than one wife the
Christian Bible says the Quran says now
you don't believe in all of them no
problem let's talk about logic let's
talk about logic sister do you know by
Nature male and female are B in equal
proportion by Nature male and female are
born in equal proportion but if you ask
any pediatrician a doctor of the
children he will tell you that the
female child can fight the germs and
diseases better than the male child so
in the Pediatric age itself there are
more male children dying as compared to
female children so in pediatric age
itself there are more females than the
males as life goes on they de due to
cigarette smoking death due to
alcoholism death due to accident death
due to war more male are dying as
compared to female so today in the world
there are millions of women more in the
world as compared to male only in some
countries third world countries like
India the female population is less than
the male population you know why because
of female infanticide according to a BBC
report BBC report according to Emily
beckin on the program letter die the
topic was assignment every day more than
3,000 fetes are being aborted in India
after they identified that they females
that means more than 1 million fet are
being Abed in India every year after
they identified their females if you
stop this evil practice and according to
Tamil Nadu government Hospital report
this state of yours that report says out
of 10 female born alive four up put to
death do you say it is right it is wrong
if you stop this evil practice even in
India the female population will become
more than the male population in America
alone there are 7.8 million females more
than male in UK alone there are 4
million female more than male in Germany
alone there are 5 million female more
than male in Russia alone there are 9
million female more than
male God Alone knows how many millions
of females are more than males than in
the world suppose sister hypothetical
question suppose my sister happens to
live in America or suppose your sister
happens to live in America USA and the
market is saturated every man has found
a woman for himself yet there will be
7.8 million females who will not find
life Partners now only option remaining
for them for these females who have got
no life partner is that either marry a
man who already has a wife or become
public property
you may say public Property Brother
Zakir such a harsh word sister it is the
most sophisticate word I can use I
cannot use the better word in America on
average the stat is tell us a person has
eight different sexual partner before
you settle down with one mist is common
you can have 10 20 30 no problem 100
also the law will not say anything if
you marry more than one wife that thing
doesn't go down their throat why in
Mistresses the woman does not get a
right she's degraded she's disor in
Islam when you have a second wife you
have to give equal rights she has the
honor she has respect but I do agree
with you sister I agree with you that no
woman no woman under normal
circumstances would like to share a
husband with any other woman I agree
with you I agree with you sister but but
the basic law of the Islamic Sharia is
let a small LW take place to prevent a
big loss mean let a small loss takes
place to prevent a big loss so all the
muslima all the Muslim women who know
that there are millions of women if they
would not allow their husband to have
more than one wife they be public
property they say we would not mind
sharing a husband to prevent our other
sisters to become public property hope
that answers the question